هذه صورة بالأشعة السينية لقفص صدري مكسور
يدور بسرعة 45 دورة في الدقيقة
وهناك صوت قادم من تلك
الأخاديد الصغيرة المحفورة في فيلم الأشعة السينية ،
فكيف يمكنك الاستماع إلى الموسيقى غير القانونية
في روسيا السوفيتية
[موسيقى
] العديد من العظماء  أشياء عن
الاتحاد السوفيتي ولكن فيما يتعلق بما يمكنك
الاستماع إليه لمشاهدته الحقيقية وما إلى ذلك ، فقد كان خاضعًا
لجهاز استشعار لذلك لم تكن هناك حرية
بهذا المعنى على الإطلاق
، حيث يدرس ستيفن كواتس من مكتب
الثقافة المفقودة ومقره لندن
عددًا لا يحصى من  طرق بارعة
للناس لتجنب
الرقابة الحكومية الصارمة في الاتحاد السوفيتي على الموسيقى التي
يُنظر إليها على أنها معادية للفكر وأيضًا
أنها قد تشجع على
السلوك الترحيبي نتيجة حظر هذه
الموسيقى التخريبية ولكنها لم تمنع
شعب روسيا السوفياتية من الحصول
على أيديهم.  كانت لدينا هذه الآلات
حيث يمكنك الذهاب إلى كشك وكان
الناس يصنعون
تسجيلات تذكارية لأصواتهم ولكن في
المساء عندما تم إغلاق المتجر ، كان هذا
الرجل يستخدم تسجيلاته  آلة
نسخ المحظورة سهلة لجعل ما نسميه
bootlegs وكان يعطيه
للأصدقاء أو يبيعهم
يدفع للجهاز لنسخ السجلات ولكن
ما هي الوسيلة التي سيسجلونها على
الفراغات التجارية مثل تلك التي تجدها
في الغرب  قلة العرض ،
اكتشفت الروح العبقري أنه
من الممكن عمل سجل لقطع
أخاديد الموسيقى المسجلة على
السطح ، أصبح فيلم الأشعة السينية نوعًا من
الثقافة السرية ، وبدأ المزيد من الناس
في عمل تسجيلات بالأشعة السينية أو بدأ الناس
في البناء  آلات التسجيل الخاصة بهم
وفي الأزقة المظلمة في الاتحاد السوفيتي ، قام
بوو لاحقًا بتبديل أصوات
إلفيس من تشارلي باركر على أمير
الحوض المكسور
والكتفين الملتوي في منتصف الستينيات ، ستظهر تقنية جديدة أسهل
في الاستخدام
على المشهد.  - مسجل شرائط إلى بكرة ،
تلاشى السوق السوداء للأشعة السينية بعد ذلك بوقت قصير على الرغم من التقدم التكنولوجي ، لا يزال هناك شيء يعيد ستيفن إلى سجلات الأشعة السينية ، وكان هناك شيء poigna  nt والشاعرية
والرومانسية حول هذا الاصطدام مع
افتقارك إلى الجوانب المادية لكونك
أشعة سينية للجسم ومحتوى
الموسيقى التي نربطها عادةً
بالروح أو بالقلب الآن
هذا ما أسميه موسيقى الروح
[موسيقى]